so obviously the first question is the
obvious one but it is the important one
how did this come about Alana what was
your inspiration for the story in the
screenplay
yeah
um at the time that I started writing
this I was thinking a lot about this
type of relationship and
um how it can be really difficult to put
it into words and to describe what it
feels like and it just felt to me like
something that would
if you if you could execute it properly
could translate to the screen really
well and it could feel like a
culmination over the course of the film
um to land the audience with an
understanding of what this character is
going through so
you know it was a bit of a challenge to
myself to do that
um and hopefully it uh it paid off well
well to understand what the character is
going through is something that you need
to really be absorbed by the film for
the duration of the film because it's
not exactly clear it is not it's not
there in the first like five or ten
pages so Adam when you read the
screenplay for the first time what was
that Journey like for you
yeah I mean I I think you executed that
very beautifully that with that
intention because I think that's it is a
really difficult thing to describe and
it's
um difficult to describe to other people
and equally if not more difficult to
identify in yourself like when it's
happening so
um I think that Alana really did a
beautiful job of creating the atmosphere
and
um there's something about this film
that I I struggle to to say like what
genre it is I usually just say It's a
drama but there's part of it where I'm
like it's the horror film yeah you know
and and you know and a lot of really
created that world and that tone and
that atmosphere of of like a horror film
where there's this impending dread that
hangs over everything because that's the
experience and you said something to me
actually
um maybe 10 minutes ago that you're not
the first person to say this that
um people have seen the film and said
um you know for like half the movie I
wasn't really sure what was going on I
wasn't sure if there was something wrong
with Alice I wasn't sure if it was in
her head and
um I I don't know if we ever put it into
those words when we were making the film
but like that is very much the intention
to give you the experience of being in
this kind of state and when you're in
that state you are very much questioning
is there something wrong with me do I
have a problem is it all in my head and
you're longing for some sort of evidence
really one way or the other and so often
it's like it it's so unclear and
um
and there was a real you know I think
you and I went through different phases
with the movie where it was like
I think there were people who thought it
would be easier better whatever simpler
to just have him throw her against a
wall just once you know just so that it
was like clear He's the bad guy and the
whole audience can relax and go okay
great he's a bad guy and we all agree
and we're all on the same page and I
didn't see the point in doing that
because I didn't want to make a movie
that I would have seen and thought oh
okay so it's not that bad you know
because that's every movie I've ever
seen about abuse was something that I
would watch and go like well it's it's
that's not happening so I guess I'm fine
and I wanted this to just be like it's
not fine he doesn't have to push you
into a wall for it to not be fine
absolutely yeah and while you were
writing the screenplay you know there
are certain tropes or or cliches that go
along with with movies or television
shows or television movies about abusive
relationships uh this is not the burning
bid not by a long shot in fact Let Me Go
going on the point of your of of saying
like we don't really know like what's
going on with Alice like does she need
help uh she's pulling out her hair and
and so while you were writing the
screenplay like how
how did you avoid those troves so what
were the conversations you had with the
director to to ensure that we would keep
people guessing up until almost like the
third Act
yeah I mean I I always had the intention
that our understanding of Simon would
evolve
um and that yeah he would only fully
come in to Clarity in the third act
um not that not to say that it was
really easy to do that definitely took
some work
um
it was really important to me that it it
was never physical it was it was all
emotional and so that it was really
about you know what this was doing to
Alice internally
um and the the flashes that occur in the
movie and that was a huge uh
uh issue I guess that we had to work
through is just how much we were showing
and
um Mary our director was like really
amazing and sort of wanting to do like
shoot them all different ways so you
know Simon would say the same thing but
maybe he'd say it three different ways
and we all felt like it's gonna kind of
we're gonna have to see how it plays
ultimately
um in the edit to really find like
what's the right
level of information to be revealing at
what stage and what's going on with
Alice that triggers like that exact kind
of Flash in her mind
um so that was scriptwise was really
challenging to get those you know you
want them on the page but you also know
it's going to be a little bit in flux
during filming and in the edit what made
Mary and I the the perfect person to
direct this film like what were the
conversations that you all have with her
about her approach to capture like what
was on the page Mary right from the
beginning like I she totally saw it and
um she has such a sensitivity and such
like a
just like Artful way of looking it's
very calming like very very poetic yeah
that's rare by the way yeah like you
never I mean I don't know maybe maybe
the producers or I don't know but for me
she never was you know like a frenetic
presence she always you know she was
very common she was also very
um like specific and generous in her
feedback to me when I was writing and
our relationship felt really like
supportive
um so that I understood what she needed
from me and you know she always gave me
the chance to like make a change if we
needed to make a change rather than just
be like I'll just do it myself yeah yeah
um and I really as a writer you know
that's that's huge I really appreciate
it your approach to Alice what were your
points of connection like how did you
like get the character and make sure you
like were were on the path I was drawn
to the script because I was coming out
of a very similar relationship
um like very very recently after when I
got the film The Script
um in fact like the first time that I
met with Mary I was like you know if the
movie was shooting in a month like I it
wouldn't be appropriate for me to do it
like I wouldn't be it would be not
healthy for me to do it um but I think
we had like six months or something and
um and I yeah it was scary but it it
also felt like you know there were so
many things in the screenplay that were
just like crushingly you know
specifically relatable
um like I remember reading that line
um you know when she loses the earring I
can't do another thing wrong and just
being like Jesus Christ
um but then there were other things
where that was not my experience at all
you know and I knew that different
things would resonate with different
people
um and I thought that
um yeah again that Alana had just really
captured
um that oppressive like suffocating
atmosphere so well and
um and I kind of knew
um like because Mary is one of the only
people which I think is right like
because she's the director and she's one
of the only people who hasn't been in a
relationship like this that she would
kind of be in the Watchtower like making
sure that nobody's story got too
hyper-specific but there were also
things where like
I think it was like day one or two they
wanted to steal this shot of me in the
hammock
um just sort of staring into space and
Mary was like oh I think you should
maybe be reading a book and I was like
oh I could I should absolutely take the
book because I would go out to the
hammock with the intention of reading
the book but my brain can't actually
focus on more than like a paragraph I
mean it's kind of funny it's kind of I
mean it's kind of funny like you know
now that it's been like two years but
um it you know at the time it's like to
be in that constant state of like fight
or flight where all I can do is try to
figure out like what do I do how am I
better how I just need to work on my
communication skills
um I just you know the only thing I
could read was self-help and even that
was like you know obsessive like
highlighter or pencil you know
um so like just little things like that
like oh I know exactly that I would want
to go out to the hammock to read but
that I would just sort of hold it
against my chest and like stare into the
middle distance was just sort of
innately there sure
um and uh I I think that kind of gave me
the freedom and just the kind of poetic
nature of the script gave me the freedom
to not hold on to these like
hyper-specific kind of tools that I
tend to reach to
um as a performer and
um meant that I could kind of shed a lot
of the armor that
by the way that I I'm proud that I've
um developed over the years as an actor
um I really always wanted to be the kind
of performer who
um you know was kind of in a dance with
the camera operator and you know knew
how to help the edit and
um could be the kind of filmmaker actor
you know and this was actually something
where I didn't want to think about any
of those kind of tools and
um just be as present as possible so it
was really vulnerable and unnerving but
it was really rewarding what's the
takeaway that you hope especially after
writing the screenplay that you hold
people take away from the film
I think I I always just hope
to make someone who watches it feel
something like I think my greatest hope
as a writer is just like
that someone will feel moved by
something that I've written
um so that
um I think sort of specifically to the
film
you know what we've talked what we've
been talking about is the idea that you
know this is enough and it matters and
it might be really hard to describe but
that doesn't mean that it's not true and
that it didn't happen and that it
doesn't affect you so I would just just
a feeling of of yeah that it that it's
real and it matters certainly and and
Anna especially for you because you
related uh what do you hope people take
from the film yeah I mean I think that
that's beautifully put that it's real
and it matters
um you know I think that they're every
now and then I'll do an an interview and
someone will will be like well yeah you
know like she's got to get out of there
like because it could get physical and
even that I I slightly object to because
it's like it it even the threat that
something could become physical like I I
don't think I Really Ever worried about
that but it it was abusive and I
deserved to leave you know so it's like
almost important to say like just this
is enough and you deserve better and you
deserve to leave and take care of
yourself and that it doesn't have to be
like before it gets physical or in case
it gets physical absolutely um so I
thought that your exploration of that
was really amazing
well congratulations and thank you
everyone for joining us for this
screening and conversation of Alice
starring please spread the word about
the movie thank you both for this
amazing company thank you